yeah but i mean that's that's part of
the reason why we're looking to move
right
yeah yeah have we talked about how we
are looking to move because we've
i mean i'm moving right yeah you've
talked about i've lived already yeah
a month ago now this right yeah
currently the process of i've applied
for a place just hoping i mean i found
out this week so yeah praying i get it i
i think re like doing the whole moving
process again
has reminded me how much of a nightmare
it was the first time to get a place
here and i just
didn't realize or i'd forgotten because
i had everything set up and now i'm
going through the process again i'm just
like
damn it was a nightmare and i'd
completely forgotten about it yeah
it's equal parts exciting equal parts
just dread
and so far it's not been too bad it's
been really annoying being rejected for
really petty reasons
yeah yeah that's been quite annoying but
that's i feel like i'm so used to that
now or i'm like
i'm not the right nationality all right
cool yeah
yeah um so i'm kind of used to it but
yeah
i mean how many places have you been
rejected from so far just one right
um two two two oh two um but some of
them were like
not rejections that didn't apply but
some of them were like oh no no furnace
oh just straight off so is that like a
rejection do you count that no that's
original because that's like
i feel like that's like 10 15 and right
like half of them are gone
yeah yeah half of the whole like
japanese housing market is just like
unavailable
yeah i'd say if it's like even more than
half like even if you have the money
to pay for this house you just can't get
it yeah for whatever reason so we talked
about this
yeah episode 2 or something yeah like
how it's [ __ ] impossible for
foreigners to write in japan it's also
you know um i feel like this happens
everywhere you have to kind of like
decide like what's important to you and
you have to like make
sacrifices depending on you know even if
you have like unlimited budget you know
there's not going to be
you know if you want to get a house in
certain areas this is not possible in
central like tokyo oh yeah i mean unless
you're actually like
buying the property but yeah you know
you don't have to do that right well
the thing is like when when i'm looking
at houses now like the first question i
ask is
has anyone else applied for this yet and
if the answer is yes i'm just like
well that like that's pretty much my
chances so
they didn't tell me this but apparently
if someone else has applied the odds of
you getting it are like super low
because it's normally just first-come
first-served
yeah and if the person before you
japanese they're probably not gonna get
rejected unless they're like super
sketchy
yeah yeah so if someone yeah like you
said they they took me to see
places and half them would already been
applied for and i'm like what am i doing
here
what so you can and of course the two
places check out this place you probably
won't get so the first
the first place they took me to visit
was five houses and the two that i
really really liked of course were the
two that had applications so i was like
great so now i've fallen in love with
two places and i can't [ __ ] help them
right like a little cocktails now you've
shown me what my standards are
and you've taken them away it's like
this is what you could have if you had a
japanese passport
hello so and so then
they i was like okay well i don't like
the other three and so we could
we find new ones yeah we found new ones
didn't like any of them and i was like
well this sucks because now i don't like
any of these [ __ ] yeah
and eventually found a few that i kind
of liked uh and i've applied for one
that i quite like um
maybe neighbors might be an issue we'll
find out but i'm gonna just sound proof
to the room before i move anything well
again that you know that's a that's a
sacrifice you have to take
yeah it's pretty [ __ ] hard i mean you
know i think i'm gonna have neighbors
yeah of course the one sacrifice i took
with my place is that like it's just
slightly kind of
out of the way especially when you go to
tokyo but everything else is [ __ ]
it's
a great house yeah